Speaker 1: My name is Jessie Dallimore, and I'm
sitting in for David Pacman while he is out.
Donald Trump's campaign kicked off in earnest, it
seems, this weekend. He was in New Hampshire and
South Carolina. And a lot of what you would
expect from Donald Trump took place in both
events. What it shows me really is it's going
to be even crazier this year than in 2016 or
in 2020 because his entire strategy has changed
surrounding campaign events. So it appears there
are far more small and intimate. Some would say
that it's just to mix things up. But I think the
any observer with any acumen or understanding
of politics or Donald Trump for that matter,
is really going to understand it as a diminished
support from people in the party. People are
tired of the games and the tricks and the the
over-the-top nonsense. But rather than change
fundamentally how he acts and what he does, it's
a tertiary change. It's just a surface level.
Difference in how he's running things, because
all of the craziness, all of the lumpiness,
all of the lies, all of the insanity is
still there. In his New Hampshire speech.
He made this bold claim about how if he were
president or if he becomes president, he will
end this Ukraine thing in 24 hours. Watch this.
Speaker 2: This guy is going to be in world.
Remember Crooked Hillary? He's going to cause
a war. In his first week in office because they
think that's my personality type. It's actually
the opposite. My personality kept us out of war.
And I told you before, what had never happened
was Russia would have never gotten it. Putin would
have never, ever gotten it. And even now I could
solve that in 24 hours. It's so horrible what
happened in those cities are demolished now. The
people, I'll bet you have millions. It could be
millions. How can you? You know, they bomb a city
to the ground. These big buildings come tumbling
down and they say two people were injured, not
two people. They lie. I mean, they lie, but.
If I were president, you would have zero
chance that that war would have happened.
Speaker 1: That is telling and quite interesting
considering the fact that just about a year ago,
February 2022, Donald Trump was on the the Clay
Travis and Buck Sexton show. They all went down to
Mar a Lago to have a good time on their podcast.
And he said all kinds of glowing things about
Vladimir Putin. He called him genius. He called
him savvy. He called it wonderful as insinuated
he was a peacekeeper. Remember this? Keep in
mind what you just watched with him saying he
would solve this problem in Ukraine. Remembering
a look back to one year ago with all of the things
that he said about Ukraine and Vladimir Putin.
Speaker 2: I've never seen anything like it.
I don't think our country has ever been so low.
You could take the five worst presidents in the
history of our country and put them together.
I don't think they've done the damage that this
administration has done. Mr. President.
Speaker 3: In the last 24 hours. We know
Russia has said that they are recognizing two
breakaway regions of Ukraine. And now this
White House is stating that this is an invasion.
Speaker 1: That's a strong word. What went wrong
here? What does the current occupant of the Oval.
Speaker 3: Office done that he could have
done differently?
Speaker 2: Well,
what went wrong was a rigged election.
And what went wrong is a candidate that
shouldn't be there and a man that has
no concept of what he's doing. I went in
yesterday and there was a television
screen and I said, this is genius.
Putin declares a big portion of the Ukraine of
Ukraine. Putin declares it as independent. Oh,
that's wonderful. So Putin is now saying it's
independent, a large section of Ukraine. I said,
how smart is that? And he's going to go in and be
a peacekeeper. That's the strongest police force.
We could use that on our southern border. That's
the strongest police force I've ever seen. There
were more army tanks than I've ever seen.
They're going to keep peace, All right. No,
but think of it. Here's a guy who's very savvy. I
know him very well. Very, very well. By the way,
this never would have happened with us had I
been in office. Not even thinkable. This would
never have happened. But here's a guy that says,
you know, I'm going to declare a big portion of
Ukraine independent. He used the word independent.
And we're going to go out. We're going to go in
and we're going to help keep peace. You got to
say, that's pretty savvy. And you know what the
response was from Biden? There was no response.
Speaker 1: He calls him a genius. It's wonderful
what took place. How smart is that? Calls him
a peacekeeper and the strongest peace force.
Does that sound like a man who's going to run
in as president of the United States and solve
the Ukraine problem in 24 hours? This coming from
the same guy who was going to have infrastructure
week, week after week after week after week, and
it never got done until Joe Biden took office.
This coming from the guy who's going to build the
wall. That everything was just about to happen.
Never getting anything done other than massive
unpaid for tax cuts that contributed to him
adding 25% or taking responsibility for not taking
responsibility for, but being responsible for 25%
or so of our total overall national debt inside of
four years. The other part this little clip I want
to share is him talking about how he invented the
word caravan. And he tells his rich friends who
aren't citizens, who want to be citizens that
what they need to do is just cross the border
and then they'll just magically be declared
citizens, I guess, by the federal government.
Watch this astounding misunderstanding or just
lies being told by Donald Trump to give you a
flavor for what's to come in this campaign cycle.
Speaker 2: And I came up with the name Caravan
because we had caravans of 15, 20,000
people pouring in. Not one, I tell you,
we had it stopped pretty early. But now,
if you look at these caravans is a massive,
massive caravans and they have no idea who these
people are coming into our country and they're
walking in unabated. There is nothing
that nobody's asking them about health,
but it's hard to get in. I have so many of
you. Can you help me become a citizen? I say,
Yeah, go to the southern border. Just walk
across the line. You know, I have a guy,
rich guy wants to become a citizen and he's going
through everything he's going to school to study
and this, this and that. He's been working for 11
years. He hasn't been able to pull it off. Okay?
And I finally said to him, You know, you've
been working so hard, why don't you just.
Go down to Mexico and sort of start walking across
the border. They'll take you gladly. They won't
even talk to, you know, how ridiculous it is.
Speaker 1: Like lots that Donald Trump does and
says it starts off as kind of a joke and then his
free association leads him to tell a story that is
almost certainly untrue, but with a serious tone
and tenor to it. He's not telling telling it like
it's a joke. He he got serious there for a moment.
He's telling people that he believes the way to do
it, as though we're just issuing citizenship
to anyone who crosses the southern border.
The issue of immigration in this country is
is such a murky topic because of the lies that
are told by the right, because of the lies and
the the abject just white nationalism that has
infected a massive swath of our country. They
talk about it like it's an invasion. They talk
about it like there's an impending war that's
going to take place. It gets the psychos in the
Republican Party whipped up into a frenzy.
And all that does is exacerbate the problem
because they're not there to solve it. There's
no evidence whatsoever that Kevin McCarthy or
anyone in leadership in the Republican Party
in the House of Representatives wants to solve
the problem. They want it to continue to be a
political football. They want it to continue
to to make hay for them be a be a campaign
slogan. It's a prop to them. They're not
there to solve problems. And it's just getting
worse and worse and worse as time goes on.